the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
my name is Arlene I work in Stata in the
Stata Center I'm a PhD student there and
my fifth year and today we're going to
be talking about one of our research
projects called Katina and Katina is a
really nice way of using Bitcoin to
build append-only locks Bitcoin itself
is an append-only log and a lot of
people have been using it to put data in
it and I'll describe a really efficient
way of doing that and it's applications
and if there's time we'll talk about
attacks and maybe colored coins and some
other stuff
we'll talk about the what the how and
the why and that's the overview of the
IMP of the presentation so let's talk
about this problem called the
equivocation problem so what is this a
in general non equivocation means saying
the same thing to everybody so for
example if you have a malicious service
and you have Alice and Bob the service
should say the same thing to Alice and
in Bob so we would make a bunch of
statements let's say s1 s2 s3 over time
and Alice and Bob would see all of these
statements so this is very similar to
what Bitcoin provides right in Bitcoin
you see block 1 block 2 block 3 and
everybody agrees on these blocks in
sequence write this down make sense
so this is non equivocation and in
substance this is what Bitcoin already
offers and and in general with non
equivocation what you might get is some
of these statements might actually be
false or incorrect non equivocation
doesn't guarantee you that this
statement is a correct statement but it
just guarantees you that everybody sees
the same statements and then they can
detect incorrect statements in Bitcoin
you get a little bit more you actually
know that if this is a block it's a
valid block assuming there's enough
blocks on top of it right so
equivocation means saying the same thing
to everybody so for example this
malicious service at time 4 he might
show Bob a different statement than
Alice so Bob sees s for analyses s for
prime this is what happens in Bitcoin
sometimes and that's how you can double
spend in Bitcoin by putting the
transaction here sending money to the
merchants and then putting another
transaction here sending money back to
you right are you guys familiar with
this yeah okay all right so why does
this matter let me give you a silly
example suppose we have Jimmy and we
have Jimmy's mom and Jimmy's dad right
and Jimmy wants to go outside and play
but mommy he knows that mom and dad
don't let him play so what he does is he
tells dad hey dad mom said I can go
outside right and then he tells mom hey
mom dad said I can go outside and let's
say mom and dad are in different rooms
and they're watching soap operas and
they're not talking to one another so
they can actually confirm that you know
mom can't confirm that that really says
that and that can't really confirm that
mom said that but they both trust Jimmy
so you see how equivocation can be
really problematic is now mom and dad
will say sure go outside as long as the
other person said that right but let me
give you a more practical example so
let's look at something called a public
key directory a public key directory
allows you to map users public keys a
username - a public key right so here I
have the public key for Alice and here I
have the public key for Bob and they
look up each other's keys in this
directory and then they can set up a
secure channel how many of you guys use
whatsapp for example so whatsapp the
whatsapp server has a public key
directory and when I want to send you a
message
I look up your phone number in that
directory and I get your public key
right if that directory equivocates the
following thing can happen what the
directory can do is he can create a new
directory at time - where he puts a fake
public key for Bob and he shows this to
Alice right and at time - also he
creates another directory for Bob where
he puts a fake public key for Alice
right so now the problem here is that
when Alice checks in this directory she
looks at her own public key to make sure
she's not impersonated and Alice looks
in this version and sees okay that is my
public key I'm good she looks in this
version okay this is my public key I'm
good so now I'm ready to use this
directory and I'll look up Bob and I'll
get his public key but Alice will
actually get the wrong public key does
everybody see that
and similarly Bob will do the same so
Bob will look in his fork of the
directory right and he looks up his key
here and his key here and he thinks he's
okay he's not impersonated but in fact
Alice's impersonated there okay and now
as a result they will obtain fake keys
for each other and this man in the
middle attack ER who knows the
corresponding secret keys for these
public keys can basically read all of
their community
patience any questions about this this
is just one example of how equivocation
can be really disastrous so in a public
key directory if you can equivocate you
can show fake public keys for people and
impersonate them so in other words it's
really important that Alice and Bob both
see the same directory because if Bob
saw this directory the same on Alice huh
then Bob would notice that this is not
the public key he had he would notice
his first public here and then that
there's a second one there and then he
would know he's impersonated and he
could let's say whistle blow talk to the
New York Times and say look this
directory is impersonating me
right so in conclusion equivocation can
be pretty bad so this idea that he say
different things to different people can
be pretty disastrous and what Catina
does is it prevents that so in general
if you have this malicious service that
is backed by Catina if it wants to say
different things to different people it
cannot do that it has to show the same
thing to everybody and the way we
achieve that is by building on top of
Bitcoin and that's what we're going to
be talking about today so any questions
about sort of the general setting of the
problem and our goals here so let's move
on then so so why is this why does this
matter
so this matters for a bunch of other
reasons not just public key directories
and secure messaging it matters because
when you want to do secure software
update equivocation is a problem and
we'll talk about that later so for
example at some point bitcoin was
concerned about malicious Bitcoin
binaries being published on the web and
people like you and me downloading those
binaries and getting our coins stolen
right and it turns out that that's an
equivocation problem somebody is
equivocal
it's equivocating about the Bitcoin
binary it's showing us a fake version
and maybe other people a real version
secure messaging like I said before has
it has applications here and not just
secure messaging but also the web like
when you go on facebook.com you're
looking up Facebook's public key and if
somebody lies to you about that public
key you could be going to a malicious
service and you could be giving them
your Facebook password does that make
sense and also it has applications in
the sense that if you have a way of
building an append-only log you really
have a way of building a block
right for whatever purpose you want and
we'll talk about that as well so the
10,000 feet view of the system is we
built this Bitcoin based append-only
lock and the way to think about is is
that bitcoin is already an append-only
log it's just that it's kind of
inefficient to look in that log if you
want to pick certain things from the
Bitcoin blockchain like you put your
certain bits and pieces of data there
you have to kind of download the whole
thing to make sure you're not missing
anything and I'll tell you why soon so
instead of putting stuff naively in the
Bitcoin blockchain we put it in a more
principled way and in the sense we get a
log in another log we get a our log in
the Bitcoin log and this generalizes to
other cryptocurrencies like you could do
this in litecoin for example or even in
aetherium though I don't think you guys
yet talked about how the etherion
blockchain works and the cool thing
about this Catina log that we're
building is that Catina the Catena log
is as hard to forecast the Bitcoin
blockchain
if you want a four-car log you have to
fork Bitcoin however unlike the Bitcoin
blockchain
Catina is super efficient to verify so
in particular remember I described the
log in terms of the statements in it so
if you have 10 statements each
statements will be 600 bytes to audit so
you don't have to download the whole
Bitcoin blockchain team to make sure
you're not missing a statement and you
also have to download 80 bytes for a
Bitcoin block and we have a Java
implementation of this and if you guys
are curious you can go to my github page
and take a look at the code alright so
before we start I know you guys already
know a lot about how the Bitcoin
blockchain but it's important that I
reintroduce some terminology just so
we're on the same page so this is the
Bitcoin blockchain we have a bunch of
blocks connected by hash chain pointers
and we have miracle trees of
transactions and you know these arrows
indicate hash pointers it's mean it
means that block and stores a hash of
block n minus 1 in it right so that in
that sense block n has a hash pointer to
block n minus 1 all right and like I
said each tree has a Merkle tree each
block has a miracle tree and everybody
agrees on this chain of blocks via
proof-of-work consensus which all of you
already know and importantly in the
myrtle trees we have transaction
and transactions can do two things right
a transaction can mint coins create new
coins so here I have transaction a it
created four coins by storing them in an
output are you familiar with output so
you guys already discussed transaction
outputs and inputs so that's what we're
going over here again real quick so an
output specifies the number of coins and
the public key of the owner of that
coins as you already know and the second
purpose of transactions is that they can
transfer coins right and pay fees in the
process so here if you have a
transaction be this transaction be might
say hey here's a signature from the
owner of these coins here here's a
signature in transaction B and here's
the new owner with public key B of three
of those four coins and one of those
coins I'll just give it to the miners as
a transact as a transaction fee does
this make sense how many of you are with
me all right any questions about how
transaction inputs and outputs work so
if you remember in the input here you
have a hash pointer to the output here
right so and in the high-level idea here
is that the output is just a number of
coins in a public key and the input is a
hash pointer to an output plus a digital
signature from that outputs public key
okay and yeah so what happens here is
that transaction B is spending
transaction A's first output right
that's the terminology that we're going
to use and I think you guys have already
used terminology like this and what in
addition what we're going to talk about
today is the fact that in these Bitcoin
transactions you can actually embed data
and I think you touched briefly on this
concept of up return transaction outputs
right so this is an output that sends
coins to a public key but here I can
have an output that sends coins to
nobody it just specifies some data and
in fact I'll use that data to specify
the statements that I was talking about
earlier so the high-level point here is
that you can embed data in Bitcoin
transactions using these operator notes
and there's a bunch of other ways to do
it actually like initially what people
did is they put the data as the public
key they just set the public key to the
data and in that sense they kind of
waste
bitcoins right they said hey send these
three bitcoins to this public key which
is just some random data but nobody
would know the corresponding secret key
of that public key so that therefore
those coins would be burned did you did
you cover this in class already maybe
maybe a little bit so but that's kind of
inefficient because if you remember the
miners have to build the suti Exocet and
they have to keep the South put that has
this bad public key in their memory
forever because nobody's going to be
able to spend it so we don't want to do
that we want to build a nice system and
a system that you know treats Bitcoin
nicely the Bitcoin miners so that's why
we use these return outputs all right so
the high-level here is that Alice gives
Bob three bitcoins and the miners
collect a Bitcoin as a fee and of course
you can keep doing this right like Bob
can give Carol these two bitcoins later
by creating another transaction with an
input referring to that output and with
an output specifying Carol's public key
all right in the high-level idea of
Bitcoin is that you don't you cannot
double spend coins and what that means
is that a transaction output can only be
referred to by a single transaction
input so this thing right here in
Bitcoin where I have two inputs spending
an output cannot happen right how many
of you are familiar with this already
okay good so actually this is the
essential trick that Katina leverages
and we'll talk about it soon and and
yeah the moral of the story the reason I
told you all of this is because you know
basically if you have proof of or
consensus in the Bitcoin sense you
cannot do double spend so this thing
right here that I said before it just
cannot occur in the Bitcoin blockchain
unless you break the assumptions right
unless you you have more mining power
than you should in that case you either
have 2 X 2 or 2 X 2 prime but not both
right
and the what Catina really realizes is
that if I put statements in these
transactions now what that means is that
I can only have a second statement I
cannot have two second statements I
cannot equivocate about the second
statements if I just restrict my way of
issuing statements in this way I put the
first statement in the transaction in
the second statement I put it in a
transaction that spends the first one so
does everybody agree that if I if I do
things in this way and I want to
equivocate about the second statement I
would have to double spend
so that's the the key insight behind our
system any questions about this so far
you know it's really hard to talk if you
guys talk back it's way easier that's an
excellent question so let's let's go
over that way the idea is that in this
output I won't burn any any bitcoins
I'll actually specify my own public key
here not just send the bitcoins back to
myself and in the process I'll pay a fee
to issue this transaction does that make
sense yeah and we'll talk about it later
okay so real quickly what the previous
work do regarding this so how many of
you are familiar with block stack one
two one two only two people okay how
many of you are familiar with key base
okay so black second key base actually
post statements in the Bitcoin
blockchain and they're both public key
directories they map user names the
public keys and for example key base
what key base does is they take this
merkel root hash and they put it in a
transaction and then six hours later
they take the new root hash and they put
it in another transaction and so on
every six hours they post the
transaction but unfortunately they don't
actually do what Catina does so they
don't have their new transaction spend
the old one and as a result if you're
trying to make sure you see all of the
statements for a key base you don't have
a lot of recourse other than just
downloading the each blockchain
each each block and looking in the block
for all of the relevant transactions
another thing you could do is you could
sort of trust the Bitcoin miners the
Bitcoin full nodes to filter the blocks
for you so you could say you could
contact a bunch of Bitcoin full nodes
and say look I'm only interested in
transactions that have a certain app
return prefix in the data and they could
do that for you but unfortunately
Bitcoin full notes could also lie to you
very easily and there's no cost for them
to lie to you everybody can be a Bitcoin
full node so then it becomes a very
bandwidth intensive process because you
have to ask a lot of full node to deal a
lot of
no it's to deal with the fact that
someone might lie to you but you either
need to download full blocks to find
let's say a missing statement like this
one that a Bitcoin full know it might
hide from you or you can trust a
majority of Bitcoin full notes to not
hide statements which is which is not
very good right so I don't want to trust
these full notes because all of you guys
could run a full note right now in the
Bitcoin network it doesn't cost you
anything and if I talk to your malicious
full nodes I could be screwed so in our
work just says look instead of instead
of issuing transactions in a sort of
uncorrelated fashion just do the
following thing every transaction in
issue should spend the previous one so
as a result if someone wants to
equivocate about the third statement
they have to double spend like I said
before right yeah so the key base is
cubits and blocks like our public key
directories and what they do is they
want to prevent themselves from is there
a white board I can draw here yeah so
let's say you know if you remember the
picture from the beginning I can have a
public key directory that evolves over
time right so this is V 1 of the
directory and it might have the right
public keys for Alice and Bob but at V
to the directory might do this mi do V 2
it might have Alice Bob but then put a
fake key for Alice and at V 2 Prime it
might do Alice Bob as before and put a
fake key for Bob so in other words it
keeps the directory append-only
but it just adds fake public keys for
the right people in the right version so
here this this one is shown to Bob and
here this one is shown to Alice so now
Alice will use this fake key for Bob so
she'll encrypt a message with B Prime
for Bob and now the attacker can easily
decrypt this message because he has the
secret key so what the attacker can do
then is Rhian cryptid with the right
public key for Bob and now he can read
alice's messages and the the whole idea
is that the attacker you know this b
prime is is the public key is a PK b
prime let's say but the attacker has
this KB Prime
he knows skb prime because the attacker
put the cinder the attacker being really
block stack or key base and of course
they're not attackers in the sense that
they want to be good guys but they're
gonna be compromised eventually so they
want to prevent themselves from doing
things like these is that sort of answer
your question yeah all right so so yeah
really a simple summary if I had to
slice the summarize our work this would
be it right there would be these two
look don't do things this way do them
this way right so let's see let's look a
little bit at the design so remember we
have these authorities that could
equivocate about the statements they
issue like block stack or key base so
what we propose is look this authorities
can run a lock server a Catina lock
server and they start with some with
some funds locked in some output and
what they can do first is they can issue
this Genesis transaction to start a new
lock so for example key base would issue
this Genesis transaction starting the
log of their public key directory Merkle
roots and this Genesis transaction can
be thought of as the public key of the
log once you have this Genesis
transaction you know it's transaction ID
you can verify any future statements and
you can implicitly prevent equivocation
about statements and and what what the
lock server is gonna do is it's gonna
take these coins and send them back to
the server to answer your question so if
there was a public key if these coins
are owned by some public key they're
just sent back to the same public key
here and paying some fees in the process
right so we're not burning coins in the
sense that we're just paying fees to the
miners which we have to do ok so now
what you can do is if you want to issue
the first statements you create you
create a transaction and you send the
coins from this output to this other
output you pay some fees in the process
you put your statement in an operator an
output and as a result if this lock
server wants to equivocate it has to
again double spend here which it cannot
do unless it has enough mining power so
key basin block stack if they were to
use a system like this they could
prevent themselves from equivocating and
this can keep going right so you issue
another transaction spend the previous
output put a new statement yes
seemed like a new problem have
authorities prevented this doesn't seem
like a new problem how did authorities
do it the problem is not new the problem
is eternal that's so you are correct
there how did they do it in the past
they just used a Byzantine consensus
algorithm so in some sense this is what
we're doing here as well we're just
piggybacking on top of bitcoins
Byzantine consensus algorithm sure I'm
not sure what rolling down means but but
yeah we're piggybacking on top of
Bitcoin the idea is that look Byzantine
consensus is actually quite complex to
get right we already have a publicly
verifiable verifiable Byzantine
consensus algorithm it's Bitcoin why
can't we use it to verify let's say a
lot of statements super efficiently so
up until our work people didn't seem to
do this so key base that and do this
block stack there and do this
they kind of force you to download the
entire Bitcoin blockchain to verify
let's say three statements so in our
case you only have to download a few
kilobytes of data to verify these three
statements assuming you have the Bitcoin
block headers right which which we think
is a step forward and it's sort of like
the right way to use these systems
should be you know the efficient way not
the inefficient because bad word is
expensive right computation is shift
bandwidth is expensive all right so
anyway the idea is that if the lock
server becomes malicious if key base or
blocks that gets hacked they cannot
equivocate about the third statement
they can only issue one unique third
statement and the advantages are you
know it's hard to fork this lock it's
hard to equivocate about third statement
but it's efficient to verify and I'll
walk you through how clients verify soon
[Music]
the disadvantages are that if I want to
know that this is the second statement
in the log I have to wait for six more
blocks to be built on top of this
statements block right just like in
Bitcoin you have to wait for six blocks
to make sure a transaction is confirmed
right why do you do that the reason you
do that is because there could be
another transaction here double spending
because sometimes there are accidental
Forks in Bitcoin and things like that
what what are some other disadvantages
that you guys can point out yeah it's
gonna be expensive to issue these runs
so Arlene Arlene and I share the same
name so Arlene is pointing out that you
know every time I issue these statements
I have to pay a fee right and if you
remember the fees were quite ridiculous
in Bitcoin so that's that's a problem
right so let's see what's that the next
thing no the next thing was you have to
issue you can only issue a statement
every ten minutes right so if you want
to issue statements really fast you
can't do that all right like Arlene said
you have to issue a bit you have to pay
Bitcoin transaction fees and the other
problem is that you don't get freshness
in the sense that it's kind of easy for
this log server to hide from you the
latest statement you know unless you
have a lot of these lock servers and you
ask many of them hey what's the latest
statement and they show you a more
called path a later statement if there's
just one lock server and it's
compromised it could always pretend no
no no this is the latest statement and
if you don't trust it the best recourse
you have is to download the full block
and look for the statement yourself so
you don't get freshness those are some
disadvantages now let's look at how
clients audit this lock so I was
claiming that it's very efficient to get
these statements and make sure there's
no equivocation happened so let's say
you have a Kachina client and you're
running on your phone with this client
and your goal is to get that list of
statements and there's the Catena lock
server over there in the back and
there's the Bitcoin peer-to-peer network
which at the moment has about eleven
thousand nodes and remember I said the
first thing you need is the Genesis
transaction does everybody sort of
understand that if you get the wrong
Genesis transaction they're completely
screwed right because it's very easy to
equivocate if you have the wrong Genesis
transaction right I mean you know
there's the right gtx here where you
have let's say s1 and then you have as
two in their own transactions right but
if there's another gtx Prime here and
you're using that one you're you're
you're going to get s 1 prime s 2 prime
a different statement so if alice uses
gtx but Bob uses GTX prime Alice and Bob
are back to square one so in some sense
you might ask okay so then what's the
point what have you solved
here I still need to get the this GTX
right so what we claim is that this is a
step forward because you only have to do
this once once you got this GTX you can
be sure you're never equivocated - right
whereas in the past you would have to
for each individual statement you'd have
to do additional checks to make sure
you're not being equivocator like you
would have to ask enough full note so
let's say right so as long as you have
the right GTX you're good and how do you
get the right GTX well usually you ship
it with the software on your phone and
there are some problems there as well
like there's no no no problem solved in
computer science in some sense but you
know we're trying to make progress here
okay so let's say you have the right GTX
because it got shipped with your
software now that the next thing you
want to do is get the block headers so
you have header I but there are some new
headers being posted let's say the
Bitcoin peer-to-peer network sends them
to you you have these headers you verify
the proof of work right so this only
cost you 80 bytes per header right does
everyone see that this is very cheap so
far so so far I have the GTX which is
let's say 235 bytes and now I'm
downloading some headers and now I'm
ready to ask the loc server what's the
first statement in the log right and
what the loc server will do is he's
gonna reply with the transaction with
the statement which is 600 bytes and the
Merkle proof so all of this is six six
six six hundred bytes actually right and
now what the Catena client will do is
he'll check the merkel proof against one
of the headers so to see in which
headers does it fit and then he'll also
check that the input here has a valid
signature from the public key in the
output here all right I want at least
one question about this yeah
yes exactly it's an SPD client yeah so
the idea is that we want as PV clients
we don't want these mobile phone clients
to download 150 gigabytes of data we
want them to download let's say 40
megabytes worth of block headers which
they can discard very quickly as they
verify and then we want them to download
600 bytes per statement but still be
sure that they saw all of the statements
in sequence and that there was no
equivocation yeah yeah hey so which one
did you say here's some transactions or
here some consummate outlets and they
yes yeah
we're not yeah we can high transaction
from you which gets back to the
freshness issue that we could discuss
they could also you know this block
header could be a header for an invalid
block but remember that before you
accept this tx1 you wait for enough
proof of work you wait for more block
headers on top of this guy to sort of
get some assurance that no this was a
valid block because a bunch of other
miners built on top of it right so as
long as you're willing to trust that the
miners do the right thing which they
have an incentive to do the right thing
you should be good but like you said
what's your name and said there are
actually bigger problems with SPV
clients and if there's time we can talk
about it but it's actually easier to
trick SBV clients to fork them and
there's something called a generalized
vector 76 attack have any of you guys
heard about this so it's like a pre
mining attack but it's a bit easier to
pull off actually it's a lot easier to
pull off on an SP vino then on a full
note and if there's time at the end we
can talk about it if there isn't you can
read our paper which is online on my
website and you can read about these
these pre mining attacks that work
easier for SPV notes but anyway this can
keep going right you get block headers
80 bytes each you ask the lock server
hey what's the next statement in the log
you get a merkel proof in a transaction
and then you verify the moral proof you
put this transaction in one of these
blocks and you verify that it spends the
previous one alright and as a result you
implicitly by doing this verification by
checking that hey this is a transaction
in a valid block this block has enough
stuff built on top of it and this
transaction spends this guy here you
implicitly prevent a quick vocation
right then you don't have to download
anything else right you only have to
download these merkel proofs and
transactions and these block headers
whereas in previous work you couldn't be
missing these s ones these s two's they
could be hidden away in some other
branch of the Merkel tree and you would
have to do peer-to-peer bloom filtering
on the phone notes and those full notes
could lie to you yeah so the bandwidth
is actually very small so suppose we
have 500k block headers i think bitcoin
has a bit more
now which are 80 bytes each and we have
10,000 statements in this log which are
600 bytes each then we only need to
download 46 megabytes right what's
what's the other way of doing it you
have to download hundreds of gigabytes
all right so let's talk about
scalability a little bit so suppose the
system gets deployed widely let's say
whatsapp starts to use the system to
witness to publish their public key
directory in Bitcoin right and everybody
a lot of you here have whatsapp and this
is you guys let's say there's 200,000
people using whatsapp I think there's
more like a billion so what are they
going to do remember that part of the
verification protocol is asking for
these block headers from the
peer-to-peer network right and in fact
if you're SPV client you usually open up
around 8 connections to the peer-to-peer
network and if you're a full node in the
Bitcoin peer-to-peer network usually
have around 117 incoming connections
that that's how much you support you
support a hundred and seventeen incoming
connections as a full node so that means
in total you support about a million
incoming connections so you know this
guy supports a million but we need about
1.6 million connections from these
200,000 clients right so it's a bit of a
problem if you deploy Catina and and
becomes a wildly popular being a bit
optimistic here but you know let's say
that happened right
so how can we fix this how can we avoid
this problem because in this case what
we would basically be doing is we would
be accidentally ddossing Bitcoin and we
don't want to do that does everybody see
that there's a problem here first of all
yeah ok so the idea is very simple we
just introduced something called a
header relay network and what that means
it's look you don't really have to ask
for these block headers from the Bitcoin
peer-to-peer network you could just
outsource these block headers anyway
anywhere because they're publicly
verifiable right the block headers have
proof of work on them so you can use
volunteer nodes that that sort of effect
push block headers to whoever asks asks
for them you could use blockchain
explorers like blockchain that info
right you could use a Facebook you can
just post block headers on Facebook I'd
like you know in a Facebook feed
you can use Twitter for that you can use
iron with github guests you know so you
cannot of ways to implement this the
simplest way is having servers and and
have them send these these headers to
whoever asks for them so it's easy to
scale in that sense because if you now
asks ask this header relay network for
the block headers a you know it's much
easier to scale this than to scale the
Bitcoin peer-to-peer network which has
to do a bit more than just block headers
they have to verify blocks they have to
verify signatures yeah so another way
and I think we talked about that in in
the paper is you can implement the
header relay network as a peer-to-peer
network on top of the clients yeah
that's another way to do it there's some
subtleties there that you have to just
be speculating wishful thinking they
could there is a there is some problem
with this header relay network as well
and we talked about it in the paper
because this header really network could
withhold block headers from you so you
do have to distribute it like usually
you don't want to just trust whatsapp
who's also doing the statements who's
also pushing the statements in the
blockchain you don't want to trust them
to also give you the block headers you
actually want to fetch them from a
different source that whatsapp doesn't
collude with yeah and you had a question
yeah there is actually one on aetherium
there's a smart contract in aetherium I
think that if you submit Bitcoin block
headers to it you get something back and
then you can just query Bitcoin block
headers from the etherium blockchain is
anyone familiar with this so I guess I
didn't include it here but another way
to do it is to just publish the header
is in a material smart contract yeah so
there's crazy ways you could do this -
yeah
it didn't sort of fetch from it you
don't need to take us but but I suspect
to put push in it I actually don't know
who funds that contract so I guess you
found that when you push maybe maybe not
because then you also want something
back why would you push I'm not sure but
we can look at it after oh yeah it's a
good question
so anyway even if this header really
network is compromised if you implement
it in the right way this should be on a
sufficient number of parties you can
still get all of the properties that you
need - meaning freshness for the block
headers that's really the only property
that you need to the header really
network should always reply with the
latest block headers so let's look at
that cost since Arlene was mentioning
the costs so to append to append a
statement you have to issue a
transaction right and the size of our
transactions are around two hundred and
thirty five bytes so and the fee as of
December 13 was sixteen twenty four
dollars for transactions if you guys
remember those great Bitcoin times I
think that it went up to forty at some
point - so it was it was really hard for
me to talk to people about this research
back then but guess what the fees are
today so so today this morning I checked
in there were 78 cents right when we
wrote the paper they were they were like
twelve cents so you know Here I am
standing in front of you pitching our
work in in two minutes they could be
back to a hundred dollars but who knows
yes you had a question
in a transaction you can have several
outputs can you have several statements
in there so that's a good question so
can you batch statements and the answer
is yes you can definitely batch
statements what we said so far is in a
transaction in a Cuttino transaction you
have this output and you have this upper
turn output where you put the statement
right and you know it spends it spends a
previous transaction but as a matter of
fact what you can do and some of you may
already see notice this is there's no
reason to put just one statement in here
there is some reason so the only reason
is that it only fits 80 bytes so you
could put easily let's say two or three
statements in there if you hash them
with the right hash function but a
better way to do it is why don't you put
here a more code word hash and then you
can have as many statements as you want
in the Leafs of that more code tree
right in fact here you could have I
don't know billions of statements so
keep in mind you will only be able to
issue billions of statements every ten
minutes but you can definitely have
billions of statements in a single
transaction if you just batch them so
now remember the blockchain will only
store their with hash this article tree
will be stored in by the lock server
perhaps or by a different party they
don't have to be the same party does
that make sense does that answer your
question yeah all right so that was my
next point statements can be batched
with Merkle trees okay so let's talk
about the why since so far we've been
talking about Lee about these statements
but what could these statements actually
be so let's look at a secure software
update so how do you do secure software
update an example attack on a software
update scheme is that somebody
compromises the Bitcoin network domain
and they changed a Bitcoin binary to a
malicious binary and they wait for
people to install that malicious binary
and then they steal their coins they
stole their data they could execute
arbitrary code and an example of this
was sort of this binary safety warning
on the
Bitcoin website at some point they were
very concerned that a state actor is
gonna mess with DNS servers and redirect
clients to a different server and make
them download a bad Bitcoin binary so
there's the attack make sense this
everybody see why this is possible you
do need to sort of accept that the DNS
service that we can only have on the
Internet is fundamentally flawed it's
not built for security so the typical
defense the typical defense for this is
that the Bitcoin developers they sign
the Bitcoin binaries with some secret
key and they protect that secret key and
then there's a public key associated
with the secret key that's posted on the
Bitcoin website right and maybe some of
you'll notice that sometimes it's also
very easy to change the public key on
the website you know if you can just
redirect the victim to another website
and another problem is that not everyone
checks this signature even if let's say
you have the public key on your computer
you know what the right public key is
only if you're like an expert user and
you know how to use GPG you will check
that signature right and the other
problem that's probably I think much
much bigger a problem is that for the
Bitcoin devs themself it's very hard to
detect if someone stole their secret key
like if I'm a state actor and I break
your computer and I steal your secret
key I will sign this Bitcoin binary and
I'll give it to let's say one guy I'll
give it to you you know and I'll just
start get you individually because I'm
really you know I know you have a lot of
Bitcoin right and then the Bitcoin devs
will never find out about it unless you
know you kind of realize what happened
then you take your Bitcoin binary and
you go with it to the Bitcoin devs and
they check the signature in it and they
say oh wow this is a valid signature and
we never signed it so somebody must have
stolen our secret key so this is really
a bad kind of the core of the problem is
that it's hard for for whoever publishes
software to detect that their secret key
has been stolen to detect malicious
signatures on their binaries does that
make sense so a solution of course is
you know publish these signatures of
Bitcoin binaries in a Catina lock so now
if there's a malicious binary being
published by a state actor people won't
accept that binary unless it's in the
Catena lock which means people in the
Bitcoin devs will see the same binary
right so let me let me show you what I
mean we
the picture so we have this Catina walk
for bitcoin binaries and let's say the
first transaction has the has a hash of
the Bitcoin point 0 0 1 tar file right
the Bitcoin binaries and this hash here
is implicitly signed by the signature in
this input because it signs the whole
transaction right so now if I put this
hash in in a Catina log I get a
signature on it for free and now if
let's say a state actor compromises the
the lock server gets the secret key you
can publish this second malicious binary
in the lock right but what that militia
state actor will want to do you'll want
to hide this from the Bitcoin devs and
show it to all of you guys right so he
want to equivocate so as a result you'll
want to create a different transaction
with the right Bitcoin binary there show
this to the Bitcoin devs while showing
this to you guys right so the Bitcoin
devs would think they're good this is
the binary they wanted to publish while
you guys would be using this malicious
binary published by the state actor of
course this cannot happen because in
Catina you can not equivocate right does
everybody see this alright any questions
about this there has to be a question on
this
No so this mechanism is called software
transparency it's this idea that rather
than just downloading software like a
crazy person from the internet and
installing it we should just be
publishing these binaries in a lock that
everybody can see including the software
vendors that created those wineries so
in this way if somebody compromises a
software vendor that vendor can notice
that in the log there's a new version
for their software that they didn't
publish so you know this isn't to say
that it'll prevent attacks you know well
what what a state actor can do anyway
is they can just do this they can post
this h2 priming here show it to you guys
including the Bitcoin devs right and
still screw everyone over but at least
these attacks don't go undetected
anymore
right so it's a step forward in that
sense yes so the idea is that you have
to double spend to equivocate and the
other example that really the reason I
wanted to start this research had to do
with public key distribution so let's
say we have Alice and we have Bob and
they both have their public keys and I
am using this letter B to denote Bob and
his public key and the letter A to
denote Alison her public key and they
have their corresponding secret keys
right and Alice and Bob they want to
chat securely right so they want to stop
a secure channel and there's this
directory which stores the Republic II
so this guy stores alice BK Alice this
guy stores Bob BK Bob
right and the directory gets updated
over time maybe Carl
Ellen and Dan registered and if you have
non equivocation if the attacker wants
to impersonate Alice and Bob he kind of
has to put their public keys the fake
public keys in the same directory which
means that when Alice and Bob monitor
they check their own public keys they
both notice they've been impersonated
right so again the idea is that you can
detect now how can how can this attacker
still trick Alice to send an encrypted
message to Bob with Bob's fake public
key is there a way even if you have non
invocation
so what's what's the attack even I have
not equivocation and I claim that the
attacker can still get Alice to send a
fake an encrypted message to Bob that
the attacker can decrypt what should the
attacker do so pretend that we are here
without without the ability to
equivocate so the attacker cannot
equivocate but I claim that the attacker
can still trick Alice into sending a
message to Bob that the attacker can
read right so now it's time to see if
you guys paid attention somebody I mean
oh no no he does not
yeah he does not have to have the secret
key the attacker just creates fake
public keys here's a hint
yeah so so I whose person should the
attacker change the key exactly so
that's that's exactly right so what
what's your name Lucas what Lucas is
saying is look even without equivocation
I had this directory at t1 I have
another one at t2 but at t3 and both of
these had keys for Alice and Bob right
but at t3 look as a saying look just put
a fake key for Bob here and that's it
don't put a fake key for Alice they're
just for Bob and now when Alice looks up
this public key for Bob here she sends a
query to the directory hey what's the
Bob's public key she gets back B prime
which is equal to Bob pk Bob prime right
Alice can tell if that's really Bob's
fake public key that's the reason she's
using the directory in the first place
she was sort of a trustworthy place to
get it from Bob can tell if Bob looks
but by the time Bob looks it might be
too late Alice might have already
encrypted a message right so again
what's the point of doing all of this
you know it's not like you're preventing
attacks right and the point of doing all
of this is that you get transparency Bob
can detect whereas right now bob has no
hope in fact so you said a lot of you
use whatsapp so you know in whatsapp if
you really want to be sure so I have a
conversation here with Arlene dryish Sol
you wanna bring your phone here do you
have whatsapp so if you really want to
be sure that you're talking to the real
Arlene and not some other guy you have
to go on this encryption tab can you can
you tape this so my phone is black and
white it's it's going through a
depression phase I apologize so you have
to go here and there's a code here right
and allene can you do the same thing you
know what I'm talking about I really
hope I don't get some weird text message
right now with the camera on the phone
okay so now with Arlene's phone is that
the same code can somebody tell me I can
see
okay so we have two seven eight two six
and two yeah so it's the same code can
you see it on the camera so now because
we have the same code here what this
code here really is a hash of my public
key and a liens public key and if we got
the same hash of both of our public keys
that we know we're talking to one
another but we won't really know that's
the case until we actually mean in
person and do this exchange right so
what this system does instead is it
allows a lien to check his own public
key and it allows me to check my own
public key this way if we check our own
public key we'll always know when were
impersonated even though I might send an
encrypted message to the wrong coleen
coleen we'll eventually find out this is
a bit confusing because we're both
called all heap so does that sort of
make sense yeah this personated you in
fact you can't even here's the problem
if you're Bob here and you see this fake
public key and you go to the New York
Times and you say hey New York Times
this directory this whatsapp director he
started impersonating me and the New
York Times can go to the directory and
say hey directory why did you
impersonate Bob and the drug he can say
no I did not impersonate Bob Bob really
just asked for a new public key and this
was the public key that Bob gave me and
it's just it's just that he said they
said kind of a thing right so it's
really sort of an open research area to
figure out what's the right way to
whistleblow here so for example one one
one project that we're trying to work on
is is there a way to trap the directory
somehow so that when he does stuff like
this you get a publicly verifiable you
know a cryptographic proof that he
really must behaved right now there's no
cryptographic proof the fact that that
public key is there could have come from
the malicious directory or could have
come from an honest Bob who just changed
his public key so yeah so again a step
forward but we're not there you know
it's just that there's much more work to
do here and I think you also had a
question
so that's that's you know that's a
chicken in an egg right so we have Alice
we have Bob and we have the attacker
Alice asked Bob is this your public key
you know
let's say B Prime let me make this more
readable so attacker right so Alice asks
hey Bob is this B Prime your public key
the attacker changes it hey Bob is B
your public key the attacker the Bob
says yes attacker forwards it yes to
Alice right remember Bob and Alice don't
have a secure Channel that's the problem
trying to solve with this directory
right so the attacker can always man in
the middle of people well people like
Alice and Bob if the attacker can man in
the middle everything then there's
really no hope and we're living in a
very sad sad world if that's the case
yeah it actually might be the case but
we'll see anyway so so yeah so I claim
here that this is a step forward but
there's still much work to do right so
we get transparency Bob can detect he'll
know he won't be able to convince
anybody but if a lot of Bob's get
compromised
you know you you're still like in a
place where everybody knows that
something's off and we'll all stop using
what's happen right by the way whatsapp
is a great tool you should continue
using it I'm just saying it's difficult
to use right like if somebody really
wants to target it they can play a lot
of tricks to still trick you so yeah so
all right we already talked about this
and yeah again if the director we can
equivocate then you know all bets are
off because now Bob will look in this
directory he'll think he's not
impersonated Alice will look in this
directory she'll think she's not
impersonated right so so the reason we
started this research is because I
really want to my thesis is I'm building
these directories that are efficiently
auditable and have a hard time
impersonating people so that's why we
decided to look at how could you do this
with Bitcoin yeah so of course there's
one project called key chat that we're
working on with some high school
students and we're using the key based
public key directory and we're
witnessing it in a Catina log so that
stuff like that doesn't happen right
okay so now let's talk about the block
chains
in general people nowadays like to say I
need a blockchain 4x right
I need a blockchain for supply chain
management I need a blockchain for cats
for whatever they've heard a lot of
crazy stories IOT self-driving cars blah
blah and and I think the right way to
think about blockchain is to never ever
say that word unless use quotes first of
all and and second of all to understand
what Byzantine state machine replication
is right and if you understand what
Byzantine state machine replication is
or Byzantine consensus you understand
blockchain and you understand all the
hype and and then you can make some
progress in solving problems in the
sense that what is blockchain so it's
what we're doing here is we're doing a
Byzantine because this algorithm we're
agreeing on a log of operations right by
the way that's what Catina does to by
piggybacking on Bitcoin they agree it
agrees on a log of operations right but
the other thing that SMR or Byzantine
consensus does is that it also allows
you to agree on the execution of the ops
in that log so in Catina you don't agree
on the execution you just agree on the
statements but there's no execution of
those statements in the sense that you
can't build another Bitcoin on top of
Bitcoin in Catina
because you can't prevent double spends
of transactions that are Catina
statements right like the Catena
statements you have to look in each one
and tell if it's correct so to detect
the double spend in a Catina backed
cryptocurrency you'd have to download
all of the transactions and you because
you cannot execute it like the Bitcoin
miners do and build this you TXO set I'm
not sure this is making a lot of sense
but let's put it another way in Bitcoin
you have block one and then you have
block two right and there's a hash
pointer and there's a bunch of
transactions here right and remember
that what prevents me from double
spending something here
like I can have two transactions in this
block that double spend the same one
here what prevents me from doing that is
exactly this execution stage right
because in the execution stage when I
try to I execute this first transaction
and I mark this out too that spent when
I execute the second transaction I
cannot
that output anymore right and Catina you
can't do anything like that with the
statements you just agree on the
statements in Katina you would put this
transaction in the log this one and then
that one and someone would have to
detect that the second one is a bad one
but actually downloading it that's kind
of what I'm trying to say here so so in
general the way you should you should be
thinking about blockchains is through
the lens of Byzantine consensus and
that'll get you ahead of the curve in
this overly hyped space right because
it's really just this you're agreeing on
a log of operations and then you're
agreeing on the execution of those
operations according to some rules the
rules in Bitcoin are the transaction
cannot there cannot be two inputs
spending the same output right more or
less there's other things too yeah what
that gives you is it allows you to agree
on a final state which in Bitcoin are
the valid transactions that's the final
state right in etherium for example the
final state are the valid transactions
and the account balances of everything
and the smart contract state for
everything and I guess you'll learn
about that later so you can build
arbitrarily complex things with
Byzantine consensus or with block chains
and in the high-level bit if you want to
look at it in other ways that you have a
program P right which could be anything
could be a cryptocurrency
and then instead of running this program
P on a single server s what you do is
you you distribute it on a bunch of
servers s1 s2 s3 s4 right and now as a
result to mess with this program P it's
not enough to compromise one server you
have to compromise a bunch of them right
okay so and some of you might also be
familiar with this term permission
blockchain so when you distribute this
program P amongst n servers where n is
equal let's say 3f plus 1 and F is equal
to 1 in this particular case in a
permission blockchain this n is fixed
right once you've set n to 4 it has to
stay for these servers have to know one
another they need to know each other's
public keys and only one of the servers
f is equal to 1 can fail if more than
one server fails then all bets are off
your program can start doing arbitrary
things in particular if your program is
Bitcoin it can start double spending
moving a little bit fast so I'll take
some questions up until this point
before I go on
you know you don't have to that's that's
kind of what the hype is about this
stuff there's like the first interesting
paper on this was 1976 or something like
that so this is 40 30 40 year old
research we've known how to do
permission consensus we used to call it
vision Byzantine consensus for 30 or 40
years right so there's nothing new there
it's just that it's very useful nowadays
to say blockchain then to say consensus
because then you get 10 more million
dollars from your venture capitalist
folks it would be it would be such a bad
idea technically to do prefer working at
permission consensus algorithm it just
completely unnecessary plus probably
insecure too yeah so now the reason you
do proof of work is because in a
permissionless blockchain this n is not
fixed and could go let's say n was 4 it
could go to 8 then it could go to 3 then
it could go to 12 another cent in other
words people are joining and leaving as
they please and the reason you need
proof of work in Bitcoin the way one way
you can look at it is that you're really
turning a permissioned consensus
algorithm into a permissionless one and
a consensus algorithm is just voting
these n folks are just voting and you
need to f plus 1 votes to sort of move
on right and if this n changes over time
like if the sin becomes bigger it's very
easy to take over a majority of the
voters if I can just add fake voters to
a permission consensus algorithm I can
just take over the consensus algorithm
in other words I can take over more than
F nodes right so the trick there is you
have to prevent that from happening and
the only way to prevent that is to say
look if you're gonna join and make my
end bigger you better do some work so
that it's not easy for you to join
because if you're a bad guy and you want
to join you know you could do that very
easily unless I require
to do some work so that's kind of the
trick and turning of permission now
concerns are going to permissionless one
and in fact the way these permission the
animals work is completely different
than Bitcoin there are much more complex
Bitcoin is incredibly simple as it
consists are good if you ever read a
consensus algorithm paper you know it's
it's it's a bit insane also to implement
it's a bit insane Bitcoin is very simple
to implement compared to these other
things
I mean Bitcoin is of course a complex
beast as well but you should look at
let's say practical Byzantine fault
tolerant paper pbft and try and
implement that so anyway why am I
telling you all of this the reason I'm
telling you all of this is because if
you want to do a permission blockchain
for whatever reason one way to do that
is to use your favorite Byzantine
consensus algorithm so that would be
lets say pbft this was a 1999 from MIT
so you could use that could have a lot
of fun implementing it another thing you
could do is you could take your program
P and just give it to an aetherium smart
contract and you know that the etherium
smart contract if aetherium if the
etherium security assumption holds it'll
do the right thing it'll execute your
program P correctly right but the other
thing that you could do actually is you
could use Katina to agree on these logs
on the under log of operations for your
program and then you could use another
to F plus one servers or replicas to do
the execution stuff so that you can
agree on the final state and this this
gives you a very simple Byzantine
consensus algorithm so remember Catina
doesn't give you execution it allows you
to agree on the log of apps to get the
execution you basically take a majority
vote if you see you have to F +1
replicas servers and if you see F +1
votes on a final state you know that's
the right state okay
because only F of them are malicious
so in fact if you use Katina with tooth
loss on replicas I claim that you can
get sort of a permission block chain
that sort of leverages the Bitcoin
blockchain to do the agreement on the
log of ops so in that sense it's sort of
a mix of a permission and permissionless
we haven't studied this like we don't
know what properties it would have so
that's future work and if you don't need
a execution for example if all you're
doing is you're agreeing on a public key
directory like here there's no execution
this directory just is supposed to stay
up and only we have some research that
allows you to proof that every
transition is an append-only directory
and if you only need execution you can
just use Katina directly as I already
told you guys for the software
transparency application for the public
key directory application and if you
want to do a permissionless blockchain
and of course you would have to roll
your own but you have to proceed with
caution there right it's not an easy
thing to do okay so let's conclude now
what we did here is that we enable these
applications to efficiently leverage
bitcoins consensus right so clients can
download transactions selectively rather
than full blockchain and prevent
equivocation right and and you only need
to get forty six megabytes instead of
gigabytes from the Bitcoin blockchain
so why does this matter these are just I
think the three killer apps secure
software update public key directories
by the way the public key directories
also are applicable to HTTPS so when you
go on facebook.com you have to get
Facebook's public key
these certificate authorities that sign
the public keys are often compromised so
they're often fake search for Google for
big companies like that and you might
use it but if you have a public key
directory Facebook and Google can
immediately notice those fake certs
it's a it's a it's a step forward and
for more of course you can read our
paper it appeared in IEEE Tripoli
security and privacy 2017 and I'll post
the slide on the github too so there are
links there and yeah so again this is
the high-level overview of everything
that's previous work and that's where
our work the difference is very small
and now we can also talk about other
stuff
in fact I have more stuff to talk but
before we do I'd like to have a
discussion with you guys if you have
questions or yeah so so you in the a
Bitcoin would would that be something
that they would one it seems like or is
it strictly separate yeah I don't think
you need to that's the whole point right
the whole point of the research is how
do we use Bitcoin without getting the
miners to accept a new version of
Bitcoin without changing Bitcoin in any
way so no I don't think there's a
there's nothing to do really we're just
we're taking Bitcoin as it is and we're
piggybacking on top of it we couldn't
change it in I mean there's a lot of
things you can do in some times but then
you get a very different system very
different we can talk about it more yeah
I think your question is really about
how do how do app store binaries how do
you verify app store binaries it's a
chicken and an egg in some sense right
is that what you're saying yeah you're
right eventually I mean in the best case
wishful thinking would be to say that
look the app store does this already for
all of the binaries that they that they
publish right allowing the developers to
make sure nobody is posting malicious
binaries on the App Store for them yes
so I really like the C key based on
Catina it seems like a missed
opportunity that they don't do this I'm
sure they have better stuff to do but
but we just really easily allow key base
let's say Cubase has a mobile phone app
it will allow that mobile phone app to
verify the directory and get much much
more security you know no equivocation
as long as nobody forks Bitcoin since
key base is already publishing these
digests but they cannot be audited
efficiently on a mobile phone I mean
they can but not securely you know
because full notes can lie yeah so
there's a big problem with everything I
said so far and nobody caught it so one
problem is that what do you do when you
run out of funds
you know remember I said the lock server
starts with two bitcoins let's say it
issues thousands of transactions starts
paying those $40 fees and it runs out of
funds what do you do then yeah that's
exactly right we just have to change the
transaction format slightly we talked
about this in the paper as well but just
to demonstrate real quickly suppose
let's take a ridiculous example which
hopefully will never happen in Bitcoin
but suppose the the Bitcoin fee is one
Bitcoin no so now I have one Bitcoin
here and I have s1 here right and now I
have zero bitcoins here
right so zero bitcoins in this output
and maybe s2 here so that that would be
terrible right now I can't I can't go on
does everybody see this is a problem
right so what Rahul is saying is look
add another input here
all right and make it take coins from
some other transaction whatever 20
bitcoins and now you get 20 bitcoins
here right so you can easily refund
transactions right there's a bit more
subtlety there in the sense that you
don't want to join logs let's say if you
have two logs gtx and gtx prime for
different applications right then they
start issuing statements as one is - you
don't want to be able to join I'm sorry
s1 s1 prime these two logs to a single
log for certain reasons right but this
doesn't actually allow you to join them
in the sense that let's say you actually
do this and join them right so let's say
this transaction here came from GT X
Prime
right and there was an s-1 Prime here
and you did this right so the problem is
this is no longer a valid Catina
transaction for this log because a valid
Catina transaction the first input
spends the previous transactions out but
but in this in this chain it's the
second input that spends the previous
output so I cannot join logs and this
matters for a bunch of reasons that we
don't have to go into a yeah so we
talked about about batching statements I
want to show you guys some previous work
so how did some previous work do this
since there we seem to have a bit of
time okay so there were some previous
work called liar liar liar liar cronies
on fire have you guys seen this so the
idea here is that it's a really nice
piece of work and lots of people in the
Bitcoin community already knows know
about this and I think it was an idea
before the paper or maybe not I'm not
sure but Paige has a similar idea so for
example suppose we have this authority
imagine this is a Catina lock server and
it publishes a transaction which locks
to Bitcoin and locks those bitcoins to
that public key and this authority
sometimes will want to say two different
things they don't want to say s and s
Prime right and it will sign the
statements with his with their secret
key but the secret key that that the
authority uses to sign statements is
also a Bitcoin secret key is the same
secret key that the authority used to
lock to Bitcoin so twenty thousand
dollars or something I'm not sure if
Bitcoin plummeted since yesterday can
never be sure is that does the setting
make sense so I have an authority it
issue statements just like before and it
numbers them with I let's say and we
want to prevent this authority from
equivocating we're not actually going to
prevent it we're just gonna
disincentivize it in the sense that if
this authority equivocates like this for
the same statement i what i claim is
that anybody can then steal that
authority's Bitcoin because equivocating
like this reveals the secret key and the
reason it reveals the secret key is
because the signature shares the same I
here so how many of you guys like
actually you did cover Schnoor
signatures right so the tej talked about
how to do this which snore exactly but
but it didn't age cover it yeah okay
great so yeah so let's let's go over
that less briefly so again the idea is
that if someone observes these two
signatures on on conflicting statements
for the same I there is this box where
you can put the two signatures and get
back the secret key and once you have
the secret key we can spend this
transaction and get that authority's
bitcoins and then there's a lot of
details to get it right because you
might notice that if the authority does
this before they do this they might
already be spending this transaction
themselves so as to prevent you from
from taking it and details on how to
prevent the authority from doing that
are in those paper and yeah and then
then you know whoever discovered this
can can spend those bitcoins and and the
idea is that this this is set this
incentivizes equivocation by locking
these funds under the secret key of the
bad authority but it does not prevent it
right so in Katina we actually prevent
equivocation we say if you want to
equivocate you better fork Bitcoin here
they say if you want I could locate you
better you're gonna lose twenty thousand
dollars right but you have to understand
like this could be a good authority that
lock twenty thousand dollars here but
the attackers are gonna be they're not
gonna care about those twenty thousand
dollars they're just gonna steal the
secret key that quick vulgate and then
the authority is gonna be left without
money if the authority is the attacker
then this makes sense but if the
attacker is not the authority then this
makes less sense because your authority
sort of risking their bitcoins on the
assumption that no attacker can
compromise them which you know if you
could do that in computer science I
wouldn't be sitting here talking to you
guys okay so now how do you do this so
do you remember snore signatures real
quickly a an easy way to do this is
using snore signatures and I think I
could be wrong but I think this new
Segway to update to to Bitcoin allows
more signatures right yeah so so with
seg width and with snore signatures you
can definitely do this and the idea is
that there's no signature if you recall
is just K plus H of M G to the K let's
say s where s is the secret key right so
this is a snore signature on M right how
many recall this right and of course
it's not just this I mean this is the
signature is really this and this H of M
G to the K so it's these two things
right but now I want to show you that if
I sign two different things I can
actually get s but if I sign them in a
certain way so remember what I said
before is I would like this authority to
sign I am and I am Prime right and if
the authority does this I claim that I
can get the secret key out but I have to
have the same I so we relax this in a in
a in a sense that we're not gonna use I
here we're just going to use this G to
the K so if your authority uses the same
Z to the K to sign then we can extract
the secret key and the way we can do
that is I'll just show an example sake 1
it would be k plus H of M 1 G to the K
and it'll be sig 1 and I guess the
associated hash let's call it e 1 would
be H M 1 G to the K right does everybody
see this and then 6 2 would be k plus h
of m2 G to the K so again I'm oh you
guys are clearly not paying attention I
forgot the secret key e 2 is hash of m2
G to the K so I'm using the same Z to
the K and the same okay right so now how
can I extract the secret key does
anybody see a solution to this
so I think what they're always saying is
that s is just sig 1-6 2 divided by E 1
- C - is that right yeah I think so see
this because if I subtract this from
this I just get H M 1 G I'm not gonna
have space here
I get let's say it here H of M 1 G to
the K minus H of them - G to the K times
s right and now I take this here in the
denominator and I simplify and I get s
right so it turns out that that that's
kind of the trick that this word
leverage is more or less the only the
only sort of caveat here is that
remember I said there's a position I for
the statement but now I'm saying there's
no longer a position we have to use this
G to the K and how do we map positions
that G to the K is another trick that
you have to do but you can do it and if
you want more details you can read the
paper and I'm sure page will tell you
even more details about this I think the
Lightning Network also leverages this
trick in some cases all right now let's
talk a little bit about some attacks if
there's time the most interesting attack
would be the generalized vector 76
attack so this is a screenshot from a
paper you can everybody see this so the
generalized vector 76 attack is is very
interesting so you have you have an
attacker right and remember the goal of
the attacker is to replace let's say
this TX 1 with that TX 2 it's gonna show
this TX 1 to a merchant saying hey I
paid you money and then it's gonna show
this TX 2 to the merchants sending the
money back to himself so the whole trick
is to fork the merchants on this side
and then to switch him back to that
right it's a sort of a pre mining attack
and this attack is very it's much easier
to pull on SPV notes because what the
attacker does is let's see he works on
the secret chain you know with tx1 in it
and at some point the main chain might
take him over might win so the attacker
kind of gives up and keeps trying but at
some point the attacker get gets ahead
right in the second chain he gets ahead
of the main chain this stuff is not
posted yet and let's say this this March
and only need only for some reason
because they're silly they only need one
one confirmation to accept this tx1 and
for other silly reasons this motion is
an SPD merchant right let's draw a
figure here so this merchant is an SPD
merchant that only needs one
confirmation to accept the transaction
so we have the attacker and we have
let's say the SPV merchant right and now
the attacker sent you know this this was
the main block there let's say this was
bi and the attacker forked it he put tx1
here and then had a confirmation on it
right so he sends this chain to the
merchant and the other miners haven't
found anything yet right so the attacker
is a bitter head so his pre-mining so
far so good
are you all with me and remember that
these are he really just is showing
block headers so these are not full
blocks he's just showing block harris if
they're much smaller blocks right 80
bytes and the blocks are missing right
so when he shows tx1 he's just showing
like a Merkel path to tx1 to the
merchant are you guys with me okay so
now he did this to the merchant and now
what the attacker is gonna do is gonna
relax sit back and post the TX two to
the you know give TX two to the miners
let's say the miners are here it's gonna
post TX two to the miners and he'll stop
mining the attacker he's not gonna mind
anymore but he got the merchants to
accept the payment and the merchant ship
the goods maybe this is an on
purchase and so now the miners they will
find the next block di plus one they'll
put TX 2 here they'll find the next
block and then the next block and
they'll take over their chain will be
the main chain and eventually this
merchant will hear about this main chain
and he'll just see the hairs of course
because he's an SPD merchant so now the
merchant just got double spent does
everybody see this right just double
spent the merchant and sort of the
fundamental problem here is that the
merchant only received block headers so
he cannot take these block headers and
broadcast them to the miners because
miners don't mind on top of block
headers miners mine on top of full
blocks so this merchant cannot has no
protection against this if he's doing
SPV if he's upsetting SPV payments if
these were full blocks what the merchant
could have done was the following the
merchant would have would have received
the full block here with the transaction
in it right so again the attacker got
ahead but now the merchant because he
saw a block he's gonna ship this block
with TX Wan to the miners because he's a
full note fool knows to do that when
they hear about a block they broadcast
it so now the miners know about this
block they're gonna continue mining on
top of it and in fact the merchant will
send both blocks right for the miners so
now miners will continue building here
so now the attacker has a bit of a
tougher tougher problem on his hands
there is still a way to trick even full
notes even if this guy's a full note you
can sort of leverage some timing
assumptions to still trick the full node
and the details are in that paper over
there but that's one way cuz someone
somebody was asking I think you were
asking am right about SPV notice how
there are less secure and this is one
fundamental way in which they are less
secure if you accept payments with SBV
notes you're really playing with fire
you know you do need a sufficiently
powerful attacker who can get ahead but
yeah okay so with that I think that kind
of concludes the lecture
any final questions
all right cool and thank you guys
[Applause]